university of illinois at
urbana-champaign
obviously a midwestern boy
i guess a phd from michigan uh off the
road
and very well known in the uh
ai sort of community in eurips and icml
with interests and significant
contributions and reinforcement learning
and online learning in general so i'll
leave it to you now yeah thanks sean for
the introduction
and uh uh thanks for the organizers uh
for having me here
and today i want to discuss a um
see if i can move this one okay now i
want to discuss and focus on a
very standard and basic rl setting where
we use a restricted function class
to approximate the optimal queue
function of the problem and we can only
do so by
learning from a batch data set without
access to the actual environment
okay so what i want is a you know this
is a very standard and
important uh scenario for uh towards
real life applications of reinforcement
learning
and what i want is a minimal simple
complexity result
that tells us the conditions under which
we can achieve sample efficient learning
what do i mind what do i mean by uh you
know minimal
well let's look at the simplest possible
sample complexity result in supervised
learning and goes like this
right so we have data sampled id from a
distribution we have a finite class of
prediction functions one of which
accurately predicts y from x and then it
is easy to show that we can learn near
optimal predictor
using log f number of samples and note
that i'm emitting you know the usual
pack parameters
and also this result is information
theoretic that is we assume
unbounded amount of computation and the
only bottleneck is the limited sample
size
which will be the case like throughout
this talk
okay so by analogy i can also try to
write down a similar like you know
101 result for batch rl and should like
look like something like this
right so we have data being state action
reward next day tuples generated from
the mdp
and this data set needs to be
exploratory somehow
to provide some coverage over the entire
state space
we'll also need to assume that we have a
function class let's say it's finite for
now
and which captures q star the function
we want to learn
and this will call the realizability
assumption
okay so now i can similarly ask can we
achieve polynomial sample complexity in
a single setting
where apart from log f the polynomial
can also depend on things like
the horizon of the problem and the
degree of exposureness of dataset and so
on so forth
but not on things like you know the size
of the state space because we don't want
to
uh we don't want to tab our approach
here
okay so it turns out that as simple as
it looks this is actually a
long-standing open problem in
rl and despite that we didn't know the
answer
there were very strong intuitions to
believe that sample efficient learning
is
impossible in the setting because all
existing works
hint that realizability seems too weak
of a function approximation assumption
for bacterial
what i'm going to tell you today is how
we obtain a positive result in
this setting thus breaking the
conjectured information theoretic
hardness
and as usual this result comes with
caveats and limitations which i'll be
talking about later
but still i find this extremely exciting
i want to share with you
okay so let's set up the problem a
little more formally you know as usual
we have the you know infinite horizon
discounted ndps
wearing a trajectory the learner the
agent repeatedly observed the current
state from a very large state space
chooses an action obtain a reward
transition to the random next state
according to the environment dynamics
and we care about policies which are
mapping from states to actions
and for each policy its goodness is
measured by this
jpi the discounted expected return under
some initial state distribution of
interest
d0 okay and as we are all familiar with
one of the key solution concepts for mdp
planning
is the bellman equations which says that
the optimal q function q star
is the fixed point of development update
operator t
and once we learn q star we can simply
take the greedy policy of
qp star which will give us the optimal
policy
and another familiar concept that will
be useful for this talk is the notion of
discounted occupancy
uh d pi as a which basically tells us
that if you run the a particular policy
pi from the initial state distribution
what kind of states and actions it will
visit along the way
okay with that standard setup
that's the standard you know mdp
planning setup but we're here interested
in the learning in particular batch
learning setting
so first of all we'll have a bash data
set uh consisting of
sars prime tuples and for some closely
i'm going to assume the
very standard offline sampling protocol
where state action pairs are drawn from
some data distribution mu
and the reward and next data are
generated according to the environment
dynamics
okay so as i mentioned before this data
set this data distribution mu
has to satisfy some exploratoryness
conditions
and a very typical standard definition
uh
in literature is called this
concentrability coefficient uh
which is a measure um and
uh if you want to know what this is
roughly about
i've put a you know standard ish
definition on the screen
but be alerted that this is not going to
be the version that i'll be using
for our result uh and and that's related
to the caveat of the approach
but i'll discuss that later in the
second half of the talk for now
just you know accept that there's some
parameter c
that describes how good the coverage our
data set provides over the state space
and the smaller this c the better
okay so and now we have the you know the
usual finite but potentially
exponentially large function class
that captures q star which satisfy
realizability
and throughout this talk when i whenever
i uh
mention an expressivity condition like
this i'm going to use the
exact version for simplicity and we can
always handle like small amount of
approximation errors
which you can find in the paper okay so
the
this is roughly the setup and the goal
is that we want to find a good
approximation of q star
such that it induces a near-opportune
policy
under the initial state distribution now
we can go back to our earlier
you know vague informal question and
make it slightly more forward now
that is with all these setup is it
possible at all
to achieve a polynomial sample
complexity where the polynomial
can depend on logarithmic size of the
function class
the effective horizon one over one minus
gamma the usual pack parameters
and the c parameter that describes the
data quality
okay and the reason that i said that we
were we had a strong
intuition for this being impossible is
because if you look at all
existing works in rl uh
all the papers had that said that no we
can't do this
unless we add additional or stronger
function approximation assumptions
and a somewhat typical and
representative
assumption which is gaining you know
more attention from the rl theory
community recently
is called this knowing hearing about my
narrative assumption which says that
your function class not only needs to
capture q star but also needs to be
closed under the development update
operator you take any function from a
function class
make one better one update it still will
stay within the functioning class
okay so um you know
that the fact that you know standard
algorithms
fail under realizability may be familiar
with many of you but
for the purpose to get everyone on the
same page let me briefly go over
some popular approaches and see where
the failure happens
right so let's say if you have a bash
data set
and a function class 2 approximate q
star maybe the very first algorithm you
can think of is
static iteration the textbook algorithm
for
uh that you know mimic uh value
iteration by solving
a sequence of least square regression
problems
right however as early as 1996 we
already know that a fitted queue
and basically any adp algorithms that
use one step bootstrap target
will diverge even with realizable linear
class and
infinite amount of data right so the
reason is that even if your function
class can represent
q star it may not be able to represent
the ground choose function for each
regression problem
we care to solve infinite q iteration
and these fix to the problem is to
assume that for any structural
regression problem we may care about
we can always represent its base of
predictor
and that's precisely this definition of
you know knowing here the belmont error
this
closure condition that i've mentioned
before
okay so maybe then you can say well this
divergence issue is caused by
uh solving the problem iteratively and
one way to avoid
it is to minimize a single consistent
loss function that doesn't change over
time right so as long as optimization
works properly
and we're giving ourselves unbounded
computation so that's not a problem
we should not see any divergence issue
so that leads to this
alternative idea of female residual
minimization or brm
where we try to minimize the violation
of belmont equation the spelman error f
minus tf
as our loss function the problem with
this approach is that we don't know how
to estimate belmont air straight from
batch data
and the naive estimator which just takes
the score of the td
error runs into this infamous double
sampling issue
in stochastic environments that there's
an overestimation term
shown in the red box and to resolve this
issue
either we need access to a simulator to
do double sampling as in bears residual
algorithms
which is not possible in the batch
learning setting
or we need stronger assumptions and more
complicated optimization
to account for the overestimation term
and that stronger assumption is
precisely a generalization
of the closure property that we've seen
before
okay and apar and you know apart from uh
adp uh and brm there are many other
approaches that you can think of
and there's a long list to go but i
promised you
we've thought about every single one of
them and they just don't work
for example there's some recent interest
in
some approximate linear programming
style methods
uh in with nonlinear function
approximation to solve batch rl
and we've investigated some of this and
while
for the value function class you only
need realize q star
uh it turns out that you need additional
function approximation
to model these so-called density ratios
or marginalized importance ways
d pi over mu because they somehow
correspond to the dual variables
uh in linear program of mdps
right and you can think of important
sampling that has its own issues and
etc etc okay so
one thing that really makes you feel
that this problem is impossible is
because
if if you start with this bare bone
setting where you're
you're just given a bag of sars prime
tuples
and a single function class f it seems
like there's a limited amount of
the the algorithmic space that's
possible is just very limited
right so the the the the number of
different
uh arithmetic operations you can do on
these like limited number of symbols
uh seems very uh limited and seems that
we have already exhausted
the algorithmic ideas or or so it seemed
okay so now with all that setup it's now
i can now tell you how do we resolve
this problem
okay so we take the hint from a very
important
uh you know old school idea uh
and i think it's very underappreciated
from the state abstraction or state
aggregation literature
okay so it turns out that there's this
classical result that tells us
learning with q-star relevant
abstractions is consistent
and what do i mean by that well
translating into the language of
function space
is basically says that if your function
space for representing q
star is not only realizable but it's
also piecewise constant
then we're in good shape we don't need
any other assumptions
essentially if if you view this from the
state abstraction terminologies
essentially what happens is that you're
just aggregating state action pairs
you're allowed to aggregate any state
action pairs if their q star values are
the same
and if you do aggressive aggregation and
and control the number of groups you
have
then you just you you basically can
reduce the complexity of the problem
drastically
and then you can basically for example
solve the problem as if it were to have
a problem or run fit eq on the piecewise
function space
whatever you do okay and this is
consistent and the sample complexity
vaguely speaking
depends on how many blocks you have in
your piecewise constant
function class okay so more formally you
can
say something like this where you know
if i have data that is fully supported
on the state action space
then q star would be the unique fixed
point
of the projected development update
operator where this tpmu
is the combination of first doing a
bellman update
then project back to the piecewise
constant function class
and one thing we know is that thanks for
the
incredible stability of piecewise
constant function classes
this tv mu is always a gamma contraction
and for the rest of the talk it will be
also useful to
define the empirical version of this tv
mu
which is what we actually have access to
from data and you know this is precisely
the operator
the projected development operator that
you would use for example if you were to
run fit eq
with this piecewise constant function
class
okay uh you know this is a great theory
but
the very first question you want you
should ask is
does a low complexity fee this uh
abstraction or this partition
always exists right and the concern is
because there are many other different
versions
types of abstractions where the
aggregation criteria is very strict
so that for some large mdps you may not
even be able to
do any kind of aggressive aggregation at
all and if you partition your state
action space to
finally you run into generalization
error issues
well fortunately this keystart relevant
abstraction idea
is an extremely you know lenient notion
and you can easily show that for any mdp
there always exists a low complexity fee
and the idea is simple right so what you
need to do basically is just to
partition your state of action space
according to the value of q star itself
right so
what i first do here is that i'm first
decree discretizing the
output of q star uh to some you know a
finite grid between say zero and one
and i can always do that and incur a
small amount of disqualization error
that the theory can totally handle so
i'm going to ignore that in the talk
so that's why for now from now on all
the q functions you will see
look like these like step functions
because i've already discretized their
output
and what you do is they just as i said
you just discretize your state action
space accordingly
and note that you can always aggregate
all state action pairs
even if they're sort of far apart in the
state action space
because we're not actually assuming any
kind of topology over the state action
space
and you should also you should totally
ignore the you know this
the real access topology in this
visualization because that's completely
an illusion
okay and and that's why like if you do
this then you're guaranteed that
however complex the mdp is however
crazily your q function like jitters in
your space
lag smoothness lacks continuity i don't
care right
because i can always get a q star
relevant abstraction
of size order one over epsilon where
epsilon is the discretization error
so i find this a very neat and cute
observation but i
i've always thought that it would be
totally useless and why is that
well you'd never expect that someone to
give you this partition to begin with
right so you may want to learn that
partition in some sense
however to as we see to construct this
partition
we need the knowledge of q star but the
entire point of
you know batch rl at least the way we
set up the problem
is that eventually we want to learn q
star itself right so this is
completely a chicken and egg problem
however in the next slide let me show
you how to make this
observation useful for the problem we're
interested in
so remember recall that our problem is
that we have an exponentially large
function class
f one of which is q star and want to
identify that from the bash data and
turns out that you don't need to go to
exponentially large
f even if just f only has
two functions this is already a very
non-trival problem
and has bothered me for like i don't
know uh more than five years
and and but actually after i realized
the solution i thought like
why did i spend five years to arrive at
this okay but anyway so
um so the problem is this right you have
two functions f1 and f2
one of them is q star you don't know but
you do want to find it
find that out from data right so
here but um now with the previous
you know the material i hope it's almost
obvious to you how to solve the problem
now right
because all you need to do is to
partition the state action
space according to both f1 and f2
simultaneously all right so i'm showing
you a little bit of visualization here
and again you just aggregate the state
action pairs whenever both functions
stay
approximately constant within the group
of c direction pairs that you aggregate
together
okay and if you do that with the same
reasoning as before
you create a partition of the state
action space
that has a well-controlled size that is
one over epsilon square
right and the square is because we're
now considering two functions instead of
one okay but but that's you know if all
we want is a polynomial guarantee this
is totally affordable
so once you have that there are many
things you can do uh
one thing you can do for example is you
know we know that uh
the q star is close to the fixed point
of the projected bellman operator
associated with this partition you've
created so then you can basically choose
between f1 and f2
you know choose whichever one that gives
you the lower projected development
error
okay so now that we've solved the
problem with two functions let's see if
we can extend the idea to an
exponentially large
f well it turns out that the naive idea
of like just
creating a partition according to all
functions in your function space
simultaneously that obviously doesn't
work
because you're you're chopping your
state action space
in a super super fine up to super super
fine resolution right so
the number of partitions you create is
like one over epsilon to the power of
f which is doubly exponential in what we
can afford
because we're gonna we we only want to
pay logarithmic dependence on f
okay so it turns out we can still solve
that problem and that brings us to the
our actual algorithm which has like a
one line description
so algorithm is called a batch value
function tournament
uh or uh bbft uh at high level we're
inspired by chevrolet tournament for
density estimation
and also existing tournament algorithms
for model selection in rl
and basically what happens is that you
take your exponentially large
function space and run the previous
procedure on
every single pair of functions okay
and for every single pair of comparison
for each candidate function
you record a project development error
like for a candidate function f but then
you take the worst case
projective element error among all such
comparisons
which correspond to this inner max over
f prime
so note that this f prime is only
involved in the objective
in terms of creating this partition v f
f prime
and otherwise it doesn't show up
anywhere else
okay so uh one concern you may have
is you know
out of f square total comparisons we
make
uh each comparison produces a partition
of their state
over the state action space but a lot of
them are just
not good at all and by good i mean cues
are relevant
and you have no guarantee whatsoever
coming out of those comparisons
so would that be a concern well for the
details you have to read the proof of
the paper
but at a high level i can tell you that
those comparisons basically don't matter
at all
and the reason is because if your
candidate function app is really good
for example it's q star itself then you
realize that
among all the comparisons that it is
involving
it is always tested against a good fee
because
that fee is always created out of itself
so it's always
q star relevant on the other hand
if you have a bad f then among all the
comparisons
there is at least one comparison to
review its deficiency
that is when this function is compared
against the q
star as as it's like you know competitor
so that's enough to reveal the uh error
and that's why we take the maximum
overall f prime in our algorithm
so um okay so that's the you know that's
basically the algorithm
and uh you know a proof sketch for why
it is you know consistent
but ultimately we want a finite sample
bound
right and it turns out that to obtain
the finite example guarantee we
additionally require two analysis
the first is concentration bound that
all our empirical quantities concentrate
around their
you know the exact versions there are
some
technically like interesting things in
the proof
but i would say overall if you don't
care about tight race it's pretty
standard
so i'll just skip over that and the
second part is what we call
air propagation right so note that the
project development error is only a
surrogate measure for what we care about
so you have to somehow uh
prove and analyze if the algorithm
successfully controls the project
development error
how does that translate to a bound um
for example the difference between the
learned function and q star
and without going into like too much
technical details
let me just say that error propagation
in our case is a little bit
non-standard and very different from a
standard
you know adp analysis where in standard
analysis you need to reason about what
kind of different distributions
you can generate in the true ndp and
what's the distribution shift compared
to your data distribution
whereas in our case we actually need to
worry about the kind of distributions
you can generate
in these mutated aggregated
mdp dynamics so that's a little bit uh
tricky okay so uh you know again like
without going to super details
let me just say that we do find that in
the literature
there's a version of concentrability
coefficient condition
that allows us to control air
propagation
in this case which is this condition if
you look at this uh
key part from remy munoz in 20
2003 and although this may seems a very
stringent
uh condition uh let me point out that it
it actually
can be provenly satisfiable in mdps
whenever your
transition matrix elements and low rank
stochastic factorization
and i'll be happy to take some offline
uh questions afterwards but
for now let's just say if we have this
uh
error propagation uh figured out then it
is
uh relatively straightforward to prove a
polynomial sample complexity
as shown on the screen
okay so before i conclude the talk i
also want to
discuss a little bit about uh the
limitations of this approach and
some future possibilities so first of
all
as all of you have seen this approach is
clearly computationally intractable for
training because we need to enumerate
over all pairs of functions
um while it is still an open question
whether we can make this idea somewhat
useful to produce more stable training
algorithms
one thing for sure is that this is
tractable
for another import important problem in
batch rl
that is holdout validation and model
selection right so imagine that you're
doing that
rl you run your favorite algorithms on
the training data set
but you're not sure about your neural
network architecture or the
hyperparameters so you run many
different versions and produce different
queue functions
now how do you choose between them on
the validation data set
without having access to the actual
environment to do rollouts
well bvfd our algorithm provides one
such answer
and i shall mention that this model
selection problem has also been studied
uh for quite some time
in the rl literature but our existing
results are
comparably very weak and uh and i've
done some work in that regime
and compare for example compared to my
own work the current result from bbft
is like substantially stronger by wide
margin
in almost every single dimension and
what's more
uh this algorithm seems actually
practical and we actually have a
ongoing empirical evaluation for
cross-validation
in model empirical benchmarks
so another limitation of this work is
that we do need to assume very strong
data assumption
and it's still an open question where
can we can
whether we can relax the data assumption
to the more standard version of a
concentrability coefficient
and i'll say a little more in the next
slide on this but there's a more even
more challenging problem
down the road is in realistic speaking
in real applications you never expect
your data set to be
completely exploratory in any sense
right
so you need to be taking care of the uh
deficient support issue of your data set
and
uh um but we're just getting started to
think about how to do that
uh in our current framework
okay so to conclude the talk i want to
give you a
little bit of a technical overview of
the landscape of finite sample analysis
for a batch gradual function
approximation so it turns out that the
existing words
uh that have you know uh for for a long
a long time
uh have mostly focused on these two
cases where we have the
the concentrability coefficient
assumptions and also have this closure
property of your function space
but if you look at the analysis a little
bit closer it turns out that you can
relax these concentrability coefficient
assumptions
by first embedding the compare
distributions in your function space
and compare them from there okay and the
the nice thing is that if you do that
you have uh these conditions can be
satisfied for example in the linear case
more
easily now the question is really like
what if we really only have
realizability right and as i mentioned
before
uh i think most of the community
community strongly believe that
this should be impossible and we have
this uh conjecture
in our xml paper last year under the
standard
data assumption and our and our
speculation is roughly like this
it seems like the variations in the data
assumptions are minor because
with closure condition they all work
equally well
right so maybe regardless of what
condition you assume on the data
like realizability on the function class
is just a non-starter
and maybe what you need is really some
structural properties of your function
class like it's
a linear maybe linear functions are easy
it turns out that both of these
speculations were totally wrong
it turns out even with realizable linear
function class
if you assume the weakest the data
assumption
it is completely intractable there's i
think
there's identifiability issues and the
other on the other hand
as we show in this work when you have
stronger data assumptions
even you have completely generic
unstructured function class
you can derive finite polynomial sample
complexity
okay so with that i would like to
conclude the talk
this work is with my brilliant phd
student ashia
and uh thank you for all and i'd like to
uh take
questions
great great a nice talk thank you very
much so there are questions but i think
we're in the same boat as before that
we're just
you know just uh past two to three you
know just
the 30 minute mark so um
ming d are you there oh yes
yes did you agree i think we'll have to
just uh postpone
questions for both talks at the end or
um okay yeah i think we can we can
different questions too after richard's
talk yeah yeah
okay this is a quick question um yeah
i don't see the one the one here is not
quick
yeah i go on so what
well there actually there is one quick
question is there anything else
any other function class where you could
not have difficulty is there anything
besides
bidding where you where it's tractable
uh sorry i'm not seeing the
chat box well then the question is
well there's a q a i'm just trying to
paraphrase
yeah no i see the question from java i
think i have quick answers too
questions or possibilities
i'm sorry um actually i misinterpreted
this question that wasn't a short
question
i think we will have to postpone until
after okay sure no problem yeah okay yep
okay